got an announcement
breaking news good stuff finally kid is
going back we're dropping episodes now
Tuesday Thursdays Tuesday and Thursday 5
a.m audio 12 p.m Pacific Time noon you
will get the YouTube video so every
Thursday Thursday starts January 31st 5
a.m audio release Tuesday and Thursday
12 p.m video release guaranteed Thursday
guaranteed every time that's what starts
January 3rd the reason why the reason
why chin I'm glad you asked the reason
why I have psoriasis because stress but
the reason why we're dropping the video
at 12 p.m on Tuesdays and Thursdays is
because of YouTube algorithm that's
messing with us we see some crazy stuff
YouTube doesn't like that so we're
getting demonetized we're getting
suppressed so this is our way to combat
that without changing the show so
without do whatever you can still do
what we want to do no censoring but no
censoring we can upload it early to see
what gets flagged so we know what we're
dealing because if we can't talk about
dicks we don't have a show yeah enough
psoriasis
foreign
[Music]
so we're we're delaying the [__] show
because he's texting about his fish
again oh my fish guy I had people in my
audience and Dania improv holding up
that dumb fish with the [__] head
they had flower flower horns yeah on
their phone bro on the phone they were
like haha and I was like I I if he sends
me another picture picture of a [__]
fish I'm gonna send him a dick pic oh
the dude don't encourage me I will I
ain't I'll celebrate that it's just
getting dicey man the thing I like the I
like these cichlids they're the most
aggressive fish yeah there's there's how
are things in the fish world I'm glad
you asked dude that's why I want to come
we gotta start every podcast with how
things are going prom be here's the
problem yeah there's South African
Chiclets right oh the cichlids yeah
there's there's American yeah and then
there's there's so there's African
there's South America imagine African
most aggressive uh South American right
up there The American's pretty chill
okay I guess nobody told me this and I
don't know how to tell if they're from
Africa or Asia hotel or South America
all fish look the same all fish matter
office all fish matter to me I don't
matter I'm not gonna dude I don't see
color bro I know that flower that flower
Horn uh black I don't know you're
attracted to all kinds I like all fishes
if you're from Africa you're from Asia
you're from the United States it's a
problem there's a problem you put them
all in the tank they're not from they're
very tribal or they're tribal dude I
don't speak the same language well I I
have a little juvenile flowerhorn he's
my favorite fish we call them crank and
then uh bumpy the big giant one right
and crank names yeah thank you crank
crank crank crank is though he's very
he's a funny guy funny fish personality
for days will make you laugh sure put
you in a good mood and then all of a
sudden I see him just chilling back
thinking like what's going on with them
like I wonder if he's getting bullied
but these fish are smart they know if
you're in front of the tank they're
gonna throw their best the warden they
wouldn't stop by today yeah they're on
their best behavior so I'm I'm like you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna turn
out the lights leave their tank on so
they can't see me I'm gonna see what's
going on so I pull back I'm sitting
there and I can see the big flower horn
just look look around he's like oh he's
gone
I'm not dude backs up
I'm like hey the [__] are you doing dude
I just I get the little one out and put
them in the other thing I'm like the
[__] just bashed him oh bashed him and
then and then I get them like let's see
what else you don't do it
I get the [__] Jeffrey Dahmer of
flower horns I I turn lights off we have
to have this little juvenile Oscar
ripped his eyes off
I was
hate his eyes
holy [__] what a [__] oh my God
how's it going that's you know this is
why the store told me I shouldn't mix
them with other fish yeah when you're
when you got fishy fish and that's what
they do isn't it they eat fish fish eat
fish right now in the ocean at all times
there's a fish having a very hard time
and that fish is going to have a hard
time and that fish is if you think great
whites don't have a hard time
talk to me when when an orca
when a killer whale shows up did I I
told you when we went to look at for
great whites in the in in South Africa
in in Cape Horn yeah uh well well there
were no great whites in the entire cape
in the entire what is it like I get what
is it the Cove look at that entire Cove
because Daddy was in town well because
two Africa Brothers showed up what's up
fellas and they were like well they ate
they found four Great Whites 20 Footers
and ate their livers they're just
missing livers they just took their
liver and they're and the Sharks washed
up on store and every other great wire
was like let's get the [__] out of the
great white check please because they
hear because they hear orcas making
noise
dude you know I went I went uh deep sea
fishing with Jay in Tampa where's I need
something to do I'm going nuts here so I
uh called all these different uh places
to go uh fishing we this guy I think his
name was Brian fourth generation grew up
in Tampa his grandpa great grandpa all
Fishers so he knows every ins and outs
of all the fishing his main gig is
killing alligators he goes you want to
go alligator hunting come back in August
when okay it's not August let's figure
it out so we go I just I was just
offered that when I was in dude so we go
uh regular uh ocean fishing he's
chumming the waters right he's jumping
the waters and so uh there I am I catch
the only bad technique look at how
arched dude I don't know the back is all
bent I don't know the technique he was
not a small fish all right put your rod
down rod down like this and then we go
in yeah good sunglasses color food
and I wish our friends not food that in
salt water not though that's the ocean
buddy okay that's the ocean here's the
problem B yeah I let him go Jay stops
recording dolphin went
cool story bro thanks put in the work
Hank eats it and then the guy goes then
the our uh tour guide the fish store guy
goes ah [__] Dolphins I go they're
coolers they're not cool we won't catch
a fish today because they know where
we're at and we're fishing and we put
fish in large so they'll eat our bait
and then they wait and then they eat the
other fish he said we gotta get away
from the Dolphins so go down the whale
fishing fishing Dolphins he's like God
damn Dolphins just falling slow oh
nobody caught any fish no they're just
they're big fish [__] blocks they just
know that me neither damn yeah I mean
like oh dolphins and then nope oh Jay
was like oh my God Dolphins ah [__] yeah
because they they'll they'll form these
circles and get them all in oh they're
just they just obliterate everything
yeah see nobody caught anything because
the stupid Dolphins God damn it you're
[__] haters man get out of here
flipper oh dude it's exhausting it was
fun though you know yeah it's a good
time there's supposed to be four hours
after two I went
yeah did you get in the water no
absolutely not it was also cold yeah a
little cold well it was supposed to be
that's why it was tough to find somebody
which is supposed to be cloudy and rainy
and the guy was like yeah I know he's
working call Captain Brian call Captain
Brian's tomorrow the weather's not great
man the sea is gonna be too rough you
get sick out there man the probably not
you know what call Captain Moses call
Captain Moses ah no tomorrow the water's
gonna be rough you know what I know you
gotta do it for you though call Captain
like Rodriguez Mexican dude sure call
Captain Rodriguez up he goes uh Tomatoes
be rough it takes Migos yeah [__] it if
you meet me there at 8am and Jay goes I
feel like we shouldn't do this you know
we'll be fine we show up like tourists
I'm that shirt that terrible shirt and
shorts Jays and shorts and tees one on
the boat going oh yeah freezing freezing
the waters weren't that rough he said
but out in the Deep ruff ruff so I was
Daddy what did was near Wednesday
because I went to the SHOT show as you
know the SHOT show in Vegas is the
biggest I think literally convention in
the United States it's five bigger than
C CES it's it's so big because it's all
law enforcement military
um contractors and Hardware so weapons
of like it's literally rifles and
silencers and and hunting gear every
Hunter every law enforcement person not
the military that's like inviting lizard
with a keto conference the crazy [__] in
the world why were you doing that well I
was doing that I had a business thing
and it was all good but here's the thing
um uh what was what was fascinating was
that
um you you go there and it's I think 65
000 [__] people are there 65 000. and
um there was a point to the story what
were we talking about before this about
fishing it's cold his shirt looking
crazy in his shorts
fishing fishing oh wasting time
wasting time well right let me say it
for you well there was that uh
it was about being maybe on a boat maybe
being killing things alligators getting
sick big dicks Janice lizzo not Keto
damn it it was it was it was oh um wait
wait
no it's on the tip of my tongue we were
talking about
we were just talking about me and my
brother I did see Tim Kennedy me and my
brother were freezing yup yup I did see
Tim Kennedy that was awesome weather
um and and had a good time I was famous
in the Tactical space you are a little
bit a little little getting stopped uh
quite a bit do you think because you
know you've done a lot of movies and TV
this is what I was gonna yes this is
what I was going to talk about so
um I'm with a guy [__] great guy uh
his name is Brian Morgan now he if you
are a Delta guy or a Seal Team Six guy
you go train long shooting with that guy
he's got a school that you're not you're
civilian you're not getting anything
long range only yeah and he's like when
he talks about he one of the great one
[__] such a good guy he goes along
just a fantastic guy when he talks about
like he lives in Idaho family man when
he talks about shooting like from a mile
and a half away that's forever yeah two
miles away I don't know like crazy
there's a whole science how to read one
oh my god oh I mean it's it's crazy
these guys are the Elite of these so you
had nothing in common right and I go to
the this this Outfitter called Eberly
stock Eberly stock is where Delta and
those guys go and serious Hunters go for
gear they have the best gear period like
they they're if Delta goes to wait they
do it when they're going on missions
they'll do it when they yeah they're
like all their backpacks all their [__]
if you're a serious Hunter why don't you
get us some gear dude
they said they would they would uh with
that jacket I have an idea for us about
it I have an idea I have an idea they
said they would totally outfit us okay
when we go hunting with a couple of
operators I'll talk to you about that oh
me too I gotta talked about that too I
have some yeah okay I'm glad you brought
that up so we're gonna catch nothing but
yeah no we're gonna go catch some [__]
well that could be me there with the elk
on my back you could not get 100 but
he's gonna be but he's gonna be alive
okay friends not food yeah yeah you
would have known everybody at that shot
show there's so many people so I mean a
Green Beret who's uh at this other place
that sells I don't know [__] rifles
and Scopes and his name is Maddie maybe
Nelson um and that Mattie Nelson was a
Green Beret if you saw him
you never know all these guys like first
of all he's about six he's tall but thin
probably
196.465.
uh cowboy boot I mean he's a cowboy big
dick yep mustache there he is what the
[__] right there on the right Maddie
Nelson great hat great guy great guy
good looking wife he was the the there
he is right on the end there okay just
like again like all those guys they can
see him you're like man he was a special
forces guy but so he was the last guy to
ever do jungle warfare training for the
Green Berets where they send you they
put you in Brazil
and you work out with the uh look at us
look at tiny me there's Brian Morgan on
the left tiny me in the middle they won
me in a carnival they won me that was a
gift they want me in a carnival no
you're the [__] guy well I am
because after because when they suck the
boys off well what they do is when you
win me I have to do whatever they say
the words I can't are not in my
dictionary no no no yeah but there's
attitude yeah and you're doing it for
America Cowboy so he uh
he would drink jungle water so so they
would give him like a little rice a
chicken bone he went in at about 200
pounds came out at 160. they saw him he
was at church and and Brian Morgan was
like I saw him in church he was 160
clearly malnourished he was drinking
jungle water because they didn't have
enough water so what happens then I
don't know if you know parasites
yeah yes his stomach five years later is
still not right he's still not okay but
um he was telling me they're with the
Brazilians now they don't have the same
standards they're you know and they're
in the Amazon like the Brazilian Special
Forces yeah and they're in the Amazon
and it's night time
Scott said the Brazilian Sergeant
whatever he is forgive me I don't know
how it does and he goes all right guys
get in the water
everybody's getting in the water that's
night time go swimming in the night time
and is that the Amazon it's the Amazon
now here's the problem crocodiles when
you when you show and Shine the Light
you see just those eyes oh those cute
then they're cute and the guy goes don't
go over don't go over to the bay to the
uh Shore over there
like stay together they're all geared up
and they're closed you guys swim okay
you can swim a mile to that rock Yonder
at night with the chronicle infested
water well
it's not Crocs there's something called
the black caiman now now they're not a
Nile crocodile but they do get up to
15 feet and they're black yeah and
they'll take it they can jump high and
bring up a black cayman please get up to
about 15 feet they're as big as anything
and they're all black yeah and take a
look at these at night yeah now these
special I'd be like why are we Crossing
this [__] River well because you're
Green Beret you gotta start you got your
special forces get in the [__] water
we're gonna swim and uh yeah there you
go take a look at that picture right
there and that's that's what's in the
water that right there that's that's in
the water there they're 15 feet that's a
dinosaur it's a dinosaur
so um dinosaur they're all swimmers
they're all men you know and they're
swimming and they get to the Rock and
you get called out your name your number
gets called out your number gets called
out and uh well two of them
just disappeared two of them disappeared
and they had a moment of silence
nuts yeah and uh two Brazilians went
missing that's correct yeah two percent
that would be a that's a black caiman
that right there that's what would you
get in the water with that because I
don't know about you but get the [__]
out of here you know what I do I go I
quit oh I quit I wouldn't even need to
see one like hey fellas we're gonna
cross the Amazon I'd go hey aren't there
uh crocodiles in this water notoriously
known yeah yeah
you're fired cool I was watching Anthony
Bourdain he went down the Congo River
they had to get an Africa to jump in the
water of the Congo where the those
crocodiles come right at you yeah you
get in the water Stark you can't see
anything because you gotta jump in the
water and take this line and tie it to
that tree and the guy was like this and
Anthony goes is he worried about Crocs
and the guy goes here and he goes I
don't blame him and the guy gets in the
water his eyes are like that and did it
anyway
well that guy was showing me around in
Tampa he's like yeah you come in August
crocodile hunting I'll show you some of
the pictures I'll 72 alligator alligator
hunter dude he goes we only kill the old
like Bulls because they'll kill the
young and I was like I like alligators I
don't want to do that and he goes no
they it's good you know for it concerns
you know and I go yeah but
um before you were killing them what did
they do
is you want to go or not man all right
whatever dude well that's why that you
can get for 400 000 you can kill a rhino
but it's a rhino that stopped breeding
and it's an old bull that [__] with the
young ones and that's when that's what
you can get you can get a tag
to shoot a rhino which is really weird
yeah I guess you need tags to do it
right yeah
you do
I love football Brennan dude we got the
Chiefs you got sent to me you got the
Niners I got the Eagles well look I got
Niners
Eagles
well they're playing each other you
[__] idiot it's next weekend that's
what I mean
I got not as Eagles this next weekend
and I got the Eagles on that game
Super Bowl we'll see on the show because
we did this pre you said I'm taking the
Niners and since this is a disaster
listen don't listen to Brian I've got
Cincinnati and no two days so go
opposite of that and if you want to make
money
there's only four NFL teams left two
Conference Championship games and only a
few more chances to make big buckaroos
with our friends at draftking Sportsbook
an official Sports spending part of the
NFL counting down the Super Bowl 57 new
customers we can bet just five dollars
and get 200 and free bets instantly not
a new customer cool you can feel the
conference Championship Thrills with a
stepped up same game parlays take a shot
at even bigger NFL payout and boost your
winnings with each leg you add up to 100
so you could parlay the Bengals and the
Niners they both win you're making bank
bro download the draftking Sportsbook
app use the code fighter do customers
who can bet five dollars on the
conference championships and get 200 in
free bets instantly only at draftking
Sportsbook with the code fighter minimum
age eligible restrictions apply see show
notes for details for details now here's
the thing guys sometimes you get in a
car accident sometimes things happen now
you get injured you can't go to work
when you sue somebody a lot of people
think you're suing the person you're
actually suing the insurance company
okay wrong and and so what do you mean
no I was just saying you're right right
okay
comment uh car accidents are uh well in
2020 they were over 5 million cargo
that's a lot of car crashes that's more
than 15 000 a day and 600 an hour okay
that's a crazy number and now hopefully
people get injured people get injured
how does your insurance handle it did it
handle it did the injured party get what
they were entitled to uh anyway the
bottom line is you can you can be made
whole there's a company called Morgan
and Morgan yeah did you know that you
don't need a ton of money to hire a
lawyer not everyone does if you've ever
been injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan it's America's largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide more than 800 lawyers and uh
they've recovered over 15 billion
dollars it's a lot of Moolah yeah so
they've got they got a lot of uh they
got a lot of uh experience basically is
it really hard it's easy it's easy it's
more like using an app than hiring a
lawyer okay oh wow it's almost like uh
the way they put it as ordering takeout
is that easy this is fantastic such a
well-oil machine yeah submit a claim
without ever having to leave the couch
yep if you're ever injured in an
accident you can check check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free unless they
win for more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter or dial
pound529 from your cell phone that's for
for the people.com fighter or pound law
pound 529 from yourself filing a claims
basically you open your phone and it's
eight clicks away or less wow yeah
yeah I was like I I that was a cool the
SHOT show was cool because I hung out
with some pretty cool guys very cool a
lot of fun they can tell stories those
military guys better storytelling than
anybody I know you love it huh I just
like I like well-rounded people who are
interested in a lot of stuff but they
can tell how many War Stories can you
hear Brian well it's not War Stories I'm
interested in what's funny about what my
experience with with operators like say
Green Berets or [__] you know these
is you know you know what you know why
they make it a lot of times why they're
in those those things
they're it's not that they're they're
really they're really they're high
social IQs oh because they gotta be a
team it's all about teamwork it's all
about about the guy to your right and to
your left and and that's what makes them
so good the selfish guys they don't make
it the guys who don't like help their
boys so that's with everything well
except for comedy but I mean yeah well
comedy the most selfish except for
Hollywood how long would they make it to
being selfish
except for yourself would you include
staying up in Hollywood right it's kind
of no they're all the same it's all the
same children yeah it's it's all so but
you can't do that in the military not in
a war zone you can't do that military
you really can't do that in uh
professional sports if you're on a team
I mean you can if you're like a Kobe or
if you're like Antonio Brown yeah
certain positions like receiver you can
not online no no no no your team the
recorder back no no no no no that's why
I told you yes that's a huge animal
but and they sent me a video how they
kill them they have like this this gun
yeah that has like a handle on it yeah
and they so they wheel them in like
you're like you're getting a [__] his
teeth are messed up he got in a fight
with another alligator you know when
they twist it ripped his jaw Jesus
Christ so he was like he was about to
die anyway so he killed him like okay
so they have that it's like a gun like
this B they have a handle like a
broomstick but it's metal yeah it has a
thing on the end and then shotgun charge
then they they rally it in like it's a
Marlin he says sometimes takes hours
which I was like okay yeah and as he
gets close both they get him close and
go hunk yep it's a 45 slug I think it's
just not for me it's too violent yeah I
know it sounds gay but no I know what
you mean
um
that's a big that's a big answer and
he's like he's like I'm sure you've done
some cool things like nothing will get
your drone going like hunting alligators
he's like because I think I've had some
dicey calls he goes oh big time he was
sometimes they're as big as the boat did
like why not just get a bigger belt so
cool
I don't do this on a [__] kayak yeah
yeah I'm not saw a lot of alligators uh
when I was I love them hunting python I
love them yeah I love all the all that
[__] but while we were hunting you know
me I'm into serial killers and First 48
all those docs all that [__] which I
could talk about the the hatchet
Wheeling hitchhiker doc on Netflix yeah
but
we're fishing dolphins have been Dix
stealing our fish no one's catching
anything like that this is lame I see a
uh frantic vehicle pull-up two FBI
agents jump out they're looking in the
water they get in the rain what and I go
oh they're looking for a body the guy
goes no oh oh you think the feds just
show up to poke around for nothing
like they're looking for a body box yeah
and they were just scanning the property
like it was a swampy-ish like narrow
Waters there like shallow Waters they're
just they had their boots on going
through the water with something some
devices looking for a body and that's
also the same area right up I think in
St Petersburg where remember that
um the boyfriend that killed the girl
they're traveling remember yeah man he
committed suicide and he killed her yeah
they were from there too Gabby Gabby
yeah but they were searching where we're
at they're searching those Waters they
thought he was hiding in there and the
guy my tour guy who's again fourth
generation he was when they were looking
there I told them boys you're wasting
your time because when they're looking
for summer he goes he would have died
from the mosquitoes he was in in this
area the mosquitoes went so rapid so
rampant he'd been [__] there's no way
yeah you don't want to be out there
and he has no tent nothing he's just by
himself out there in nature no chance
I've been out there yeah he's like he's
he's like he's like if you guys want him
to be dead you better hope he decide to
hide here switch gears for a sec um I
had an experience on my podcast today I
interviewed a guy named James Bamford
wrote a book called spy fail about the
NSA Ruth Chris let me wrote my mom text
me about your podcast
um said this is the borest thing I've
ever heard no just kidding she said
um it's from my mama
said
uh tell count I love this podcast with
Peter Zion Zion it was so educational
interesting
um reading his book about global issues
so I just read his book so that's what
I'm doing I'm reading their books I read
the book that he this guy James Branford
he wrote a 500 page book on the NSA
National Security Agency that that is a
giant ear they eavesdrop on everybody
and I learned some [__] bro bro you're a
JFK nut
now this is a guy who is an
investigative journalist who has done
more research like incredible researcher
okay this mustache I wouldn't want that
guy Mike dude the NSA is trying to
prosecute him twice for his first work
for his mustache first work
um and his mustache
um homeboy uh looked at the Norwood
operation Norwood you know about an
operation Norwood this you'll like this
so people think that that these guys
wouldn't have killed Kennedy okay they
wanted to get they the the chain of
command the joints cheats Chiefs of
Staff under Kennedy wanted to get Castro
so badly and they were like we could
invade but we'll get a lot of backlash
for invasion they tried so what they
said is they literally had plans to
create terrorist events on U.S soil
these were Joint Chiefs of Staff like
cursed Le man those guys that said let's
let's go to the public Americans
should The Americans on our street and
bomb buildings and blame Cubans and then
we'll do this September 11th I'm sorry
we'll get a remote control plane this is
Alex Jones [__] I would have been like
[__] but this is from James Bamford
from his book and he does exhaustive
research this is actually a matter of
fact no it's a matter of public record
it's from the Freedom of Information Act
where he got access to their files now
check it out then they said we'll get a
remote control plane we'll put CIA
operatives on it they'll get they'll
leave on the back way we'll get a video
of them being students we'll blow it up
in midair
but they but then they said if John
Glenn when he goes to space if his PL if
his rocket blows up we'll plant evidence
that points to the Cubans they were
willing to kill Americans it was signed
off on this is 1975 I believe it was
signed off on my every Joint Chiefs of
Staff and it was stopped when Robert
McNamara saw it and said he was a
secretary of defense I think at the time
or something and he goes uh our chief
staff he goes no he goes we're not doing
this but all of those guys signed off on
it and I said to him I go uh I
understand that why people believe these
men killed John F Kennedy oh yeah and
he's like I just want the Republic on
the side I said do you think John F
Kennedy was killed by these guys and he
goes I'm not in the business of
speculation I I'm only in the business
of actually showing you what the
research said yeah so
we do this we do this does he say
research points to something oh yeah
because there's like a lot of things too
where they do think Russians were
responsible for killing JFK but we
didn't want to give him that maybe
notoriety so that's when they put in
Harvey Lee's Oswald like well he's
American well I mean Lee Harvey Oswald
was probably actually a patriot he was a
marine correct he might have been a
plant like Oliver Stone it does a good
job oh and when you see what these men
are willing to do to Americans it's not
at all surprising that they would do we
can see why how conspiracy there's like
if you hear that which that's a fact
right that's perfect
operation no word Operation Paperclip
all this stuff like there's that stuff
in history that is fact not conspiracy
you can see how people can take that
right or wrong and apply it to September
11th whatever it is
me too the more you look into like oh
[__] here's a great here's a great day
of pigs all that [__] you're like yeah
he opens the bomb this podcast drops
tomorrow by the way for anybody I think
or Wednesday Wednesday uh he he opened
um he he opens a book with something
called I think it's called Sony as the
first chapter
now I don't know if you remember but
Seth Rogen and our boy
um Franco Franco James Franco do a movie
called the interview
yeah North Korea let's kill Kim Jong-un
a spies now when they wrote the
screenplay it was a fake name Seth Rogen
decides no let's uh he's a stoner he's
like let's let's actually use Kim
Jong-un
uh Amy Pascal who is the head of Sony or
head of Sony programming for movies
she'd had one failure after another at
this point she was worried about her job
and Sony so she goes this is going to be
it we'll use Kim Kim Jong-un it'll be
controversial great for sales everybody
go to the movie theater very cool very
cool let's create a frowns upon that
well North Korea saw the trailer and the
trailer has Kim jong-un's head blowing
up yep okay and Kim Jong-un went um uh
absolutely [__] not you guys are
making a movie about my assassination
what if we did that about your president
what would happen you it would freak
yeah so so now
they decide they're gonna wage war they
don't know how yet
well the NSA of course is I don't know
if you know this it's a it's a city the
NSA is a city between Baltimore and
Washington DC it's the giant ear that
eavesdrop on everything oh they they
have all you know they've seen my dick
they can see everything yeah like this
guy they spy on Americans and Edward
Snowden proved that and nobody got
prosecuted they spy on Americans okay
cool
and so and it's a it's a city I think
they something like they use more
electricity than [__] like Baltimore
I don't know what it is but they have
their own chip factory in there it's got
50 buildings and all that [__] somebody
some employee of the NSA they don't know
who it was to this day he called himself
Shadow broker [__] steals half a
billion files half a billion things that
are higher than top secrets
and it's all about how the NSA Spies all
the programs all the all the stuff God
goes on the internet
goes on the [__] internet and goes he
goes um
hey uh who who wants to buy this [__]
nobody will buy it
you don't want this problem he's like
what the [__] who nobody wants to buy it
he got like I think 300 000 offer he's
like I'm selling you the nsa's top
secret information like how they do
business like this is the United States
government but guess who bought it up
North Korea and that's right and that's
when they get these that's when they got
the emails and that's when they that's
what everybody and then they they
launched Wanna Cry which was a virus
that was a computer pandemic that shut
down hospitals everywhere from England
to Scotland that shut down trains in
Spain that that even got Russia and shut
down Russia everything was shut down for
a stupid movie now I think Democrat uh
the Democratic uh Senator uh Liu or
maybe he's a congressman from Hawaii
calls up and frantically he's chair of
the uh the intelligence committee he
calls up the NSA goes hey [__] guys
nothing works they're shutting down the
world this Wanna Cry things they're
using our [__] weapons against us God
where's the kill switch Yeah
all the NSA scientists are like uh
computer science are like
um we don't we don't know we didn't
think someone's gonna what do you mean
you don't know what do you mean you
don't know everything is being shut down
we can't people are going they're in for
open heart surgery computer boom can't
do it life-saving operations people die
in the waiting room I mean crazy right
so they don't know what to do right like
no the top guys have no we don't know
what to do
like a movie right so a 22 year old kid
who is a hacker on vacation name is
Marcus Hutchins or Hutchinson's real
Patriot dude this kid goes I think I
know how to I know the I think I know
how to do this guys they're like huh
he's like a hacker there what'd you say
there he is we're even Marcus
Hutchinson's that kid's a [__] hero
British computer researcher hero now
look at this kid yeah
he uh he goes I think if you reverse
engineer this it'll shut down he figures
out a way to [__] do it and Saves the
World he's they they they'd say he saved
the internet do they give him a billion
dollars and then they arrested him
I mean let's just arrested by the FBI
Was preparing to return to England from
Defcon on six hacking related federal
charges
creating Kronos
saved the [__] he saved the internet
and and Edward Snowden Edward snowden's
a [__] hero still can't come back but
this [__] was like hey they're
they're spying on you everybody here's
half a million and no one did nothing no
nothing nobody's ever been arrested
nothing and and then the best is
Operation Holly was going to arrest them
operation Hollywood uh hey look when
they released the emails of like uh no
no Bubba Arnon miklan Arnon oh this book
is sick
space
m-i-c-h there it is oh there it was yeah
yeah now he's an Israeli businessman
he's the biggest that guy right there is
the biggest producer you've ever met
okay he's the biggest producer net worth
3.3 billion produced 12 Years a Slave
JFK Heat fight club Mr and Mrs Smith
Pretty Woman the biggest [__]
producer in Hollywood right he's an
Israeli spy sir
and that's from Israel and that's from
him
really good friends with Robert De Niro
uh made his money selling the apartheid
regime in South Africa has been involved
in over 130 full-length Motion Pictures
yes sir now now he also uh he also has
been committing Espionage against the
United States too yes 30 years he's been
committed he got all the nuclear
triggers which are fiercely guarded he
got all in the group literally we know
this we know this took them from the
Pentagon got him from Pentagon and
brought him to Israel total nuclear
smuggling every time the state
department every time anybody in FBI or
or anything was wanted to bring him down
they can't get them no because because
Netanyahu the Israeli president calls
and calls like you know Trump or
somebody goes hey uh we need him to be
safe and they say well and they put it
away it's all the [__] that Sam Tripoli
talks about and all these guys and I've
been the whole time I'm like [__]
[__] it's about time hey welcome and
now they're thinking about making a
movie about his life is an Israeli spy
in America and he's he's directing it
that you would go you would be put to
death for that that's treason he's been
spying celebrated I know and Brad Pitt
by the way he's 78 years old living in
England and uh and still still kicking
it still 3.3 billion dollars okay
I'm glad you came over to the goods made
his money as an arms dealer selling arms
to the white supremacist government of
South Africa okay yeah not a great guy
or just uh all right businessman
somebody's gonna do it Israel needed
South Africa's uranium to make a nuclear
weapon otherwise because it's because
for them their survival was linked to
having the ability to deter anybody
tried to kill him yeah defense so they
were like you know it sucks but we got
to do what a cool life though what a
life well why because he's an Israeli
spy he controls Hollywood huge chances
he's making billions of dollars billions
of dollars he was a soccer star bad guy
probably a bad guy but soccer maybe or
he's awesome and and the biggest
producer sounds awesome
and I think and I think was basically
friends with guys like Warren Beatty and
Jack Nicholson oh all those guys
sometimes they have they had some good
times oh you don't leave his dick skin
side so whatever deal he made with the
devil or whatever he he you know but
listen Patriot you know Israel was like
but the of the people that exposed him
were the Israelis that's what's amazing
about Israel the Israeli press and the
Israeli [__] government arrested him
and brought him back for a possible uh
he got out of it well because he was
best friends with Bibi Netanyahu because
he bought the prison yeah I don't know
man what a book but what a crazy guy
some people live a [__] life I think
about our life compared to this dude
what have you done they have all the
money you're Shilling sandals and he
didn't pay taxes for 10 years oh my God
but he just made it up no because Bill
no because when he gets 3.3 he calls the
president did they just drop his taxes
and the president of Israel calls the
president of the United States and the
president United States goes oh yeah
that's uh top secret
this guy's awesome dude well he's he's I
don't know
the book is called spy fail no what was
the Hollywood book that's the one I'm
interested in the Hollywood book yeah
this is in the book with Warren Beatty
no but it was Hollywood something on the
book operation Hollywood yeah operations
in the book but they're yeah but you got
to read this called operation Hollywood
no but this I don't know but this this
book How The Pentagon shapes
yep
that's the book I'm reading right now I
forget the name of it but but it's the
book that the show Blackbird was created
off of if you don't Blackburn no and I
called Stevie right away this Steve it's
Stevie blue eyes eyes it's it's Stevie
blue eyes yeah
it's a young handsome kid Charming can
talk his way in out of anything is great
with people great social skills he gets
busted in uh I forget where he's from
but he gets busted you know selling
drugs so and he he gets caught and he
thought he was gonna be able to do a
plea deal and they give him 10 years his
dad has cancer and him his dad are best
friends saying oh [__] out here get out
the FBI come to him and go hey there's a
serial killer in the worst prison in
America he we have him right now for one
murder he's committed like 15. we need
you to befriend him and get more
information we can find the bodies if
you do that we'll let you out early he
goes I don't [__] anything about serial
killers they go we know but you're
perfect guy for the job because you
you're so charming and trustworthy we're
gonna now you're gonna go over there
it's dicey but if you survive you can
get this information we'll let you out
of prison so he's like [__] I see my dad
this all true story wow agrees to it
goes over there the circular is a
terrible human being awful human being
become their cell mates they're they're
like right next to each other they
become friends he gets information out
of them oh it's a book's nuts wow nuts
wow yeah so I watched the series I'm
like what's the greatest story I've ever
heard it's a real story found the book
it's great damn that's so good yeah well
part of uh part of the this guy being a
movie producer was that Israel wanted to
create uh like they want to create a
narrative they want to create propaganda
for um that's what Hollywood's doing
right now all day every day yeah
it's interesting man but I watched a doc
speaking of the serial killers well I
guess I wouldn't call him a serial
killer but it's called
the the hatchet wielding hitchhiker oh
yeah did you watch it oh I no bubbly
here's why I didn't watch it I saw his
face and I went he's a schizophrenic I'm
not gonna watch something about it let
me give it let me give you the plot of
this so I had nothing to do I'm I'm in
Tampa me and Jerry hang around the the
Airbnb I might guess things trending let
me see what's going on here
so he goes viral
so so he goes viral because there's a
accident this guy's trying to harm this
lady or something he's a homeless
hitchhiker and he has a hatchet and he
defends this lady according to him
defense lady hits the guy over the head
twice and then turns it to the blade
side hits guy in the head and then they
interview him he has a bunch of Charisma
and he's like you know he's outgoing
he's fun and he blows up blow it goes
viral this like 2008 goes viral the most
famous guy in the in North America at
the time was super viral all these new
stations all these people are trying to
reach out to them Kim Kardashian's uh
producers go this guy needs his own
reality show so like we got to find him
he will only talk this one news anchor
that got his email because he's homeless
but he has a phone so he has emails so
the guy goes hey I don't know if you
notice but you're gonna make millions of
dollars dude like so many people want to
work with you to try and find him Jimmy
Kimmel because he was doing that back in
the day before he got all woke and it
was fun he he uh would have people that
go viral on the show Jimmy Kimmel has
them on
so he goes on Jimmy Kimmel they put him
in the hotel room he pisses in the lobby
and like what the [__] are you doing
dude oh no he's crazy they put him in
the hotel room and they said there's
there's like a fifth of Jack Daniels he
walks in they go he doesn't sip it
I need another one all before Jimmy kill
him
the guy who does Jimmy Kimmel who books
all these people he goes he goes I see
you know the kids
video goes viral he seems fun
interesting he goes but I'm driving with
him by myself I think to myself hold on
this kid got famous from hitting another
man in the head with a [__] Hatchet
see what are we doing here right this
can't be safe no goes on Jimmy Kimmel
crushes it Jimmy Kimmel goes you're so
fun and fantastic we're gonna have you
back tomorrow we're a new segment with
you you're gonna be a reoccurring
character on my show we're a new segment
where where you watch you give us
breakdowns of famous movies
they don't realize he's [__] crazy
yeah and he's not always on so they they
have him back and they go we're trying
to get him to watch Zero Dark 30 and
he's just talking about conspiracy
theories and they go okay we can't do
this just watch the trailer and they go
he can't focus he's all over talking
crazy [__] leaves nobody hears from him
he starts to get more famous on the
streets everyone's like oh it's you he's
all over Instagram all over Twitter
everyone's taking pictures with him
but it gets dark because he he he sings
too he's a musician so they're gonna get
like b-roll they're like what do you
like to do because I like to play the
guitar he walks in the Guitar Center off
Sunset and they're like it was gonna be
terrible guitar pretty talented start
seeing you guys like holy [__] this is a
legit song another musician sees it goes
hey come with our band goes play with
the band gets all drunk he's out of
control and as he's singing the lyrics
he's talking about how he killed a guy
how he killed a guy how he wasn't
defending a lady how that guy he knew
the older guy uh that he said he was
defending against and he gave him a weed
uh you give him some weed laced with
like PCP the guy started freaking out
and then he started to beat him and
people just saw him beat him thought he
was defending him so the whole thing's a
lie and so the the leader of the band's
like the [__] who lied like this guy's
famous off a lot of this is [__] nuts
so then when he does Kimmel
again the cops arrest them because
they're looking for another murder and
they think he's a suspect so they arrest
him he gets on Bail still make the camel
he goes away for a little bit he like
skips Town whatever
he would do some weird gay stuff for pay
all of a sudden this older gentleman
who's uh like a judge or some [__] in
New Jersey is murdered
and so the cop goes well how is he
murder he was hit in the head with a
hatchet
and he goes really he was yeah and then
the cop goes oh I remember this famous
homeless dude hit a guy and got famous
from that I didn't want this any
correlation they found a a bus ticket
receipt in the in the murders uh where
the guy was murdered in his house
they'll received there let's go back the
cameras they see him and that gay judge
hug him like holy [__] Tim and he's on
try he had put in prison for life I'm
sure it's dude you watch it but everyone
like the Kim Kardashian's producers who
want to give him reality show all these
the this person who specializes in
Celebrity reality shows all of them like
I mean like you talk to me you can tell
he's crazy and like all of them there we
would call like somebody whoever we
worked for and go hey man this guy's
famous for hitting another guy in the
head with a [__] ax we're gonna give
him a reality show like yeah but it's
Charisma he's homeless and here so many
people Vibe with him but he blew the
[__] well he's he's a paranoid
schizophrenic can I watch him it's so
interesting the the documents are so
interesting let me see him on Jimmy it's
definitely worth a watch
so we'll cut this up yeah all right
Jimmy has a tough gig that's how how
tough is it well the kids
but here's so what Jimmy was trying to
do there and the kid just missing the
missing the queues there yeah what he
would do and that's what the producers
were saying who were like yeah he's a
star because like he had this really
nice backpack someone gave him after
they saw this stuff and he saw another
guy who had less than him and in front
he wasn't doing it for the cameras you
go up the game back here man you need
this more than I do or like Jimmy said
they gave him like 500 bucks so a
homeless guy doing worse he gave him 500
okay he needs more than I do they're
like oh there's a kindness in there and
he talks like that like this kid's a
star there is it's crazy there's a kind
of stuff but he's not predictable
because then he'll go crazy well like
like when they caught him for killing
that guy thinking what happened he goes
man he goes so uh he told me I could
stay there he's just messaging me and
he's like you can stay at my house you
gotta stay there and I was drinking with
him next thing I know I woke up and you
know and my pants were down he's behind
me and he was raping me and they're like
oh really and he was like yeah and uh
and then he put on when he got out
because they didn't have enough evidence
to book him then so he got on Facebook
goes uh a guy says you can stay at his
house you have a drink with him you wake
up his penis is in your butt and your
pants are down around your ankles and
you wake up with [__] on your face what
would you do I would expect all you to
kill him as well so like admitted to the
murder Jesus so then the cop goes
interesting so just we did some the
forensics on the the man who died both
his orbitals were broken which is the
hardest bone to break in the body
besides your femur his his ear was
ripped off he had every Rib was broken
like he was Beat to Death and he goes
and you don't have any marks on you
though the kid goes yeah I have to
defend myself
and I go it doesn't sound like you
defend yourself and it was oh crazy and
he goes uh just New Jersey do the death
penalty wow you're like holy [__] yeah
you know I mean he'll spend the rest of
his life yeah that's that's that's uh
that's just a kid I so I I had a friend
who uh went paranoid went a little crazy
so what's really sad is a lot of men in
their 20s and 30s develop schizophrenia
and so you see a lot of people on the
street talking themselves and stuff they
still don't know why but it mostly
affects men and you end up on the street
it's such a tragedy for a family because
there's nothing you can do now if they
take medicine they're okay A lot of
times you can fix you can control it
with with uh certain medicines you
control it but the problem is they don't
take their medicine and then they they
go off on that stuff and my friend used
to
um it was so uh see it can be
successfully treated antipsychotic
medications now they have some pretty
strong side effects sometimes but they
they are helpful my buddy used to go off
his meds and he would like he would call
my other friend and say um hey uh
Obsession such as father's trying to
kill me so I got to stay put
and you'd be like what the [__] are you
talking about and then my my buddy uh
Jimmy found our friend just on the
street corner in front of his apartment
he was on the corner and he was like he
was just standing there and he was
catatonic and you know catatonic is yeah
it's when you're just your mouth is open
and you're just standing like this yeah
I've had some fish go get a tonic what's
that I've had fish go catatonic okay
well there you go then too much ammonia
too much ammonia in the [__] water
sometimes
yeah but there's nothing you could do
man he would just go crazy now he would
get really really really paranoid and
not sleep for four days and then go
crazy whatever it was but they don't
they're not sleeping they don't know but
that kid was clearly you're homeless for
a reason you're out there well even his
mom was like they interviewed his mom
she's like yeah normal child because I
guess he was saying like on Mother's Day
he's like I was good I grew up I was
only allowed two hours of sunlight my
mom would lock me in the room and mom
was like first of all that's not true
she's like he got lots of love and yeah
I told to stay in his room a lot of the
time because he would be like six or
seven years old acting like this she's
like you'd wake up at like 3 30 a.m he's
six yeah I'd put him back in his room he
couldn't leave the room because we
weren't up and he was a young child so
they want him one around the house by
himself so this is the other thing about
schizophrenia they think that people who
have schizophrenia and mental illness
are not sleeping even though they're
sleeping they're not sleeping so their
brain it's not getting into REM so
they're dreaming when they're awake so
they're having they're they're Jesus
Christ right so like you know how your
dreams make no sense they are awake but
they're actually their brain is dreaming
so they're in rem when they're awake
that's what they think so they're trying
to figure out a way to get you to sleep
I know I'm real balls deep enough you
know fish don't uh have REM sleep I
didn't know that isn't that crazy I
didn't now are they always swimming no
well when they swim they because they
have to swim to breathe so one side the
brain shuts down when they sleep but
they never the other side is awake yes
because they have to keep giraffes are
that way no right crazy sharks
everything see how long during rafts
sleep I think it's two hours a night
that's it yeah a giraffe really uh-huh
because one side one side of the brain
shuts off but when it's only one side
they never get into REM 4.6 hours all
right it's all about the same as a
giraffe let's say about five hours
really yeah wow but that's why I tried
to go if I'm not doing stand-ups I'm in
bed by 9 00 p.m if I'm not doing
stand-up
have you seen nine to five have you seen
their sleep cycles are quite short
lasting 35 minutes long because
otherwise they get eaten have you seen
the standing Babas of India who uh let
me say it again have you seen the
standing Babas of India no who are they
yeah well I'll tell you what they are
they take an oath to never
ever
sit down or lie down but to stand for
the rest of their lives hell yes even
when they say smart and uh they smoke
copious amounts of weed to deal with the
pain
now why are they doing this uh it's part
of it there are certain sects of
Hinduism where you Corporal and
Punishment tend to help bring spiritual
life yes a self-inflicted corporal
punishment yeah bring up some pictures
of their their feet what happens to them
legs it's not are they not like healthy
uh no they tend to die well that guy's
standing there yeah they'll take turns
on each leg and stuff oh wow they look
awful yeah it's not a good thing it's
not good that guy looks like Steve Aoki
after 365 Day Tour yeah people come
people come people come to talk to them
let me see the guy with his wiener out
which one is it the only one oh they get
crazy look at that down there go to the
chubby one with the wiener let's go down
look at that yeah look at me yeah but
you gotta go see what their feet turn
into
oh I've done feet right there go down
there Bubba which one there right there
yeah let's see what that's about no that
was the camera that's a camera your foot
turns into account I was gonna say wow
then look at this skinny guy right there
they do some heavy [__] and they will
smell well it's so stupid all the weed
yeah
that looks like my feet oh no it's not
good my feet look just like that [__]
doesn't work well no you need to reset
your body and rest yeah
yeah they sleep what a stupid thing
probably right standing Babas
but you know dude have you uh [__]
these guys in their feet and they're
stupid predicament look at that
is he's sitting though
caught him see here I got them
you're resting dude yep probably 90
degrees gotcha that's what you're doing
all day let's snitch on them that should
be our new job we go around snitch on
Babas Baba's yeah
yeah people come and support them it's
so stupid yeah not a way you want to
spend your life no have you have you
started that that world Phenom show The
Last of Us on HBO you just hear about
now uh-huh
am I the only one I heard about it too
what the [__] this is what happens when
you're old so so it would start off it'd
be so weird if you die just now you're
like
Brennan did he just die no it uh it
started off as a video game on
PlayStation huge game and then HBO
decided to make a series out of it it
bro it is it's the next like so it's
only it's Second Debut only the Game of
Thrones 10 million viewers the first
night last night was the second episode
it is fantastic Brian you don't say it's
so crazy so it's basically
like that makes it seem a little like
cartoonish but it's it's kind of cool
because so a virus is a cordycep it's
like this fungus that can't live in
human bodies but somehow adapt to human
bodies so this fungus takes over human
bodies kind of like a zombie but more
realistic so these humans get taken by
the fungus and like last night's episode
not spoil it but it started in uh you're
not spoilers no I'm not gonna spoil I'm
just tell you how the fire started it's
that virus the fungus virus then it
starts in Bangkok somehow is like the
perfect time for the fungus to get
inside the body
so this lady gets it whatever and she's
like uh like a rice Farm or whatever the
rest in the what happened to her she
goes she bit 10 other people and killed
him oh so it makes you crazy I mean you
go crazy you start biting yeah they're
just like zombies but but more realistic
so it's not like and they don't look all
stupid when the fungus takes over it
looks like legit you know but so they
asked this uh like disease specialist
they bring her into top disease specials
to India they know what should we do and
she goes hold on the corset fungus has
adapted into humans and she was that's
unheard of and she was it would there's
no way to stop if it spreads there's no
cure there's no vaccine what happened to
this lady when she got infected she was
basically zombie started buying people
killing people and and she goes oh my I
want to go home you know what she was
only see my family because the world's
over she was there you go hold on so
there's no vaccine what should we do and
she goes you have to stop start bombing
India right now kill everybody and reset
she goes I want to go back home with my
family this is the only way you can stop
this
geez you have to bomb every single human
here before it spreads to the world
bomb them but it's just cool because
it's more realist than zombies because
it's not real you're like holy [__] dude
the first episode
first 10 minutes like oh I'm in holy
[__] I gotta watch this the last on HBO
HBO's not playing around no no how's the
dragon okay this Pedro Pascal is amazing
he's in everything dude so he's part of
narcos you ever heard of it oh yeah Game
of Thrones yeah the unbearable weight of
massive Talent dude you look at the
shows he's been uh Wonder Woman from
1984 yeah he's a bad guy from that what
Mandalore yeah mandalorians and
everything he's in everything he's
massive he's awesome so good he's so
good in this and then I posted this on
my Twitter there's a scene he's all
right there's a scene from a video he's
all right if he wasn't successful
wouldn't say that yeah he's cool yeah
he's like a seven but they they they
they posted a video from the actual
video game when when uh a person in his
life dies they do that from the actual
video game scene and then his scene dude
it is spot oh you're like holy [__]
don't tell me anymore he's so good dude
don't tell me oh you gotta start
watching it yeah probably the most
accurate video game to series and I
don't I feel bad for people to know the
video game because they know how it ends
and what's gonna happen I was never into
the video game so I'm watching it for
the first time I have no clue what
happens it's so [__] good
favorite show
it's right up there Game of Thrones
House of dragons whatever happened to
that actor they said where's that
[__] actor that was in uh
he was in thank you for not smoking
Aaron Eckhart
I don't see him in much
he's being a lot of [__] oh he isn't
like Batman too right yeah what happened
he's two-faced from The Dark Knight
right but when something happened
something something went on
or maybe I'm wrong but I just don't see
him in a lot oh you you were talking
about you Thank You for Smoking yeah oh
he was in the core in 2003
uh no he's still doing stuff he's in
Rumble in the dark the bricklayer all
right Ambush he's still working all
right doing the damn thing station all
right but yeah he's uh two-faced and
Dark Knight that was a hot second ago
wasn't it sure was
that's a lot of actors right you're like
what the [__] happened it was like so
hot and for some reason something
happened
why Hollywood won't cast oh okay
internet card pretend to lose it oh go
back I told you internet I pretend to
lose a child and support group while
preparing for a role in Rabbit Hole uh
reveals he attend a sport group for
parents who lost their children pretend
to lose his own child while preparing
for his role with too deep too deep he
did method so did that come out
oh wait no that's not it here it goes go
back that's not it no one's gonna get
two minutes why Hollywood won't cast
yeah click on that click on that
uh internet card may have familiar name
and face but he's never quite reached
the same amount of Fame but claimed
enjoyed by some of his peers the actor's
dramatic turns and films like all right
oh all this [__] yep okay every singers
Hollywood has seemed too cool on Eckhart
a bit although he has no trouble finding
straight work it's been a while yeah big
budget bombs that's part of it like
that's probably the biggest one dude
because he's two-faced that was huge
movie keep going all right
um carving out film identity okay this
is stupid what did he do
opinion that comfort zone movies
rewriting a reputation
what's that oh it has a ripe dish for
being difficult to work with
he made to the Garden that he once took
out professional frustration that's fine
oh no this is stupid you just wanted to
you know you know what's promised he's a
white male in Hollywood
okay solved uh there's not they're not
exactly chomping the bit to hire a white
guy in Hollywood right now
I'm not saying there's a problem with it
but I'm saying that he's not high demand
you feel me you feel me okay you're
feeling me and black panther three bro
there you go buddy well Tim what do you
got should we uh should go some
current events yeah give us a future
current events we got some current
events current their events and their
current events and news of current
events funny new stuff
apparently George's fight
is on YouTube now it was not on for a
while whoa It's on the which channel
would it be on uh Spar star MMA awesome
and this is just a little clip that rich
child sent me okay of Georgie after the
fight post fight so yeah I'll just play
it for you guys real quick if I know
George he's crying
just finished my first fight didn't go
to where I wanted to but God damn in my
crowd my team they were there for me
every time of the way thank God for them
I'd like to give a special thank you to
Brendan schaab and rich without them I
want to have made any of the friends I
have in LA and I
you know I don't know I'm just so I'm so
thankful
thank you guys you're awesome George
George tell us tell us about the walkout
tell us how to feel like this experience
you know tell us about the lockdown
my walk out for one my walkout song was
hit
sister that little Park
okay and you know I'm a Chicago boy I
had to pick a Chicago Rapper made me
pick it up a little bit it was pretty
surreal pretty surreal that's awesome
I'm 100 Gonna Keep training at Burbank
Legacy I would like to look into getting
Skin Surgery from my excess skin for my
weight loss uh I've been putting it back
a little bit because of this fight
program and everything but I would like
to start looking into that a little bit
more and then after that I would love to
if my train is going good and I'm
confident I'd love to come back
I should message to all the people that
have supported you all the people online
all your friends family.com
everyone that has been here for any part
of my journey whether it was two years
ago one year ago one day ago I don't
care if you were there for me I
appreciate you eternally you have given
me more confidence than I could ever
give myself and for that I really do
thank you guys
so good George so [__] good we're
gonna get that surgery done man me and
bird got money on it yes sir how how
much money are we away uh I think with
you and Bert we're two-thirds of the way
but how much is it total I think like
around 10 grand but I wanna go to the
doctors we'll get it all set up we'll
figure that out buddy hell yeah proud of
you man but I love you guys thank you
yeah awesome to see you man I love
seeing you like that yeah all right I
bet you what Jen doesn't have on current
events the Asian guy who shot up the
place oh [__] Brandon I think I did why
do you gotta make it about race every
time very rare an Asian guy does that
hold on I just saw something there
there's a bunch of stuff here but I did
have the Asians that one last huh
you know so I know the story the Asian
guy so basically there was a 70-ish year
old man that went it was like during the
Chinese lunar new year and where was it
Alhambra I think it's a very huge
Chinese community in Alhambra and it was
like a you know it's like a banquet hall
where people would do dancing and all
that kind of stuff performing and the
Asian guy that worked there with his
family he's the one that disarmed that
Rob the guy so that guy apparently
before killed what 11 10 11 people 10
people yeah and then uh he walked into
this uh Ballroom area and why did he do
the guy who did it was a white guy no no
he's an Asian guy oh he's an Asian yeah
an Asian guy I thought he said the Asian
guy disarmed does exactly so the Tunisia
guy was a perpetrator and an Asian guy
disarmed him got it
it was white it'd be the first hey man I
always no got it and then why wouldn't
why did he shoot up the place why
there's no real true like there's no
real solid motivation for 11 people well
let's see usually there's a lot of
parking ticket and although usually
there's like his wife so his ex-wife I
think was at that Ballroom before and
then he was 70 and he did it I'd be like
well it took a long time for him he
thought they were talking [__] about him
maybe his wife told him stuff and he
thought his wife was talking [__] about
him so he he's just out of his someone's
gonna kill 11 people 10 people people
at 70 though he gotten this far in life
without stepping no he wasn't 70 though
no he wasn't 70. yeah the guy who did
the shooting yeah
hold on dude you don't know [__] about
this past shooting in California I I you
don't know [__] about the biggest hidden
TV you thought it was a white guy
and yeah he so he did commit suicide he
went to once the guy got his gun from
him the Asian dude yeah he kind of like
sort of stayed around for a little while
and then jogged to his van and
apparently that's when the cops came and
he shot himself holding him huh I don't
see how if you're not the guy rips again
you don't shoot him he didn't like give
me this he's like just go away get out
of here get out of here so bro I had a
little skier on the plane I fell asleep
about four hours took a red eye because
my son had his first football game at
Sofi so I had to make it on time by 9
A.M so I take the red eye and Falls I
fall asleep on my plan I wake up people
help we need help I'm like what I'm
sitting first class they run up like
what the [__] run up and my in my head
I'm like oh it's Isis whatever they got
box cutters oh I pop up there's a guy
next to me the Hollywood guy I'm like
you know the way I pop up and then
they're like he's having a seizure I'm
like oh thank God and then I sat down
there he goes God if something were to
go down I want you on the Fly I'm like I
don't play that [__] dude I ain't gonna
let Isis take over this plane
that's incredible
stud oh man bossies so cute in the Bosa
Jersey
I still tell you I'm like you know how
crazy is your first [__] game is that
sofa he's like yeah whatever I'm like no
it's not whatever
foreign
he's out dude that's amazing
what else yesterday uh this is a real
quick one I guess there's a diff there's
a bunch of different 7-Eleven stores
this is California Texas and New York
that are using classical music to shoe
away the homeless people that you kind
of hover around the homeless people
don't like classical music
they're actually making it really loud
too so apparently that is making it's
actually working he's showing the data
if you want to hang out at 7-Eleven yeah
that's weird that's what I did I wonder
who figured that out yeah like hey Jerry
why have no homeless I don't know how to
play this loud classic music yeah I mean
this problem is that these [__]
they're everywhere and these these until
they start stealing earplugs
all right there it goes I don't know how
he found the study but still he's just
showing their customers annoying operas
annoying and I'm assuming they're
correct because it's working well that's
not true
we gotta deal with these people doing
drugs and [__] and you're you have a
business your whole livelihood people
can't even come to your store and he's
saying you're the bad guy if you [__]
tell them to get out of there oh I
stepped in human [__] the other day suit
my son Jitsu it's off intro down there
you know it's kind of a nice year I step
in [__] I'm driving like I turn around
because Boston interior with me I go
when you guys [__] your pants like no
I'm like hey I'm driving like man you
know human shit's the worst in my new
cartoon like who [__] their pants dude
[__] and I roll down a window and it's
just in my face I'm like mother did I
shave my pants yeah I'm checking I'm
like what the [__] am I looking at my
shoe and I there's a difference between
dog dude this was a fresh human turd on
my shoes squished into it damn to see
you so [__] up throw that thing away
oh stupid human [__] bye-bye human
bye-bye um
favorite shoes too I don't care if China
comes in with those like anti-clock
hoses get the [__] out of here I mean
someone else's poo poo oh the worst I
mean if I'm wipe my ass I just get a
little bit of brown on the thumb rest of
the day bro I'll cut myself the rest of
the day I can't do it mission impossible
so disgusting yeah I uh um they've
ruined everything uh in San Francisco
they were in the city with that [__]
oh dude I forgot to tell you because of
the fish tanks I'm always have my hands
in the water yeah broke out in hives
yeah you get you have a white ick yeah
look look at look look at my skin that's
called the egg bro yeah whatever let me
see I'm gonna turn that's a virus of
some kind oh I'm taking pills for it and
I have a look at spots all over my body
now good for you I noticed that not my
wiener though
everywhere but the wiener legs look like
[__] monkey Punk do you have all that
oh on your legs oh let me see
oh you broke out into a [__] oh
that's uh that looks like Siri that's oh
that's psoriasis what the hell is that
let's say it's from stress you got
psoriasis yeah this is from stress Bubba
and fish tanks you got psoriasis that's
not a fish tank that's psoriasis you
have what I used to have yeah I know
you're going through some [__] you gave
it to him yeah but you never had it
before then right no so that means
that's that is oh that is when Brian had
it I had the exact same thing jokes on
me remember when I made fun of you yeah
that's so funny now isn't it you covered
your whole body covered yeah except for
my weiner no we don't get it well I
wonder why I don't know but you're
you're why not just make the rest of
your body oh
yeah I look like a monkey bar I look at
Monkey pox and [__] talk what's reho
yeah what's your brother aren't you born
with the whatever that's uh that's
stress stress yeah and it goes
and all that damn probably it's like
legit psoriasis oh that's right that's
legit I first thought that was chicken
pox thank you for sharing by the way I
like that you're what's weird is it's
got I think a lot better than the kid
this has been 10 years when you when you
when you uh oh yeah she's on your legs
I've had a few this morning and now it's
fun that's here to stay oh no I look
like that'll be there for a while oh no
I look like Tom Hanks from Philadelphia
right now that's here to stay first wait
yeah no no that's that's good
old-fashioned surroundings my weiner
it's an autoimmune it's long clearance
day thick yep juice yeah I was about
your age when I started getting that so
now it's all gone though so we're gonna
talk I got some solutions for you
because the medication they give me
aren't working clearly medication I have
pills don't let them put you on Humira
you can't get life insurance that was
terrible biologics terrible idea are you
already on it well I don't know they
gave me like six like I had to take six
pills yesterday I don't know the lotion
does nothing yeah and then the I took a
shot
bit of steroids yes that was a steroid
it did nothing no no you don't want to
do anything they put on my shoulder
don't do any of that bubble well I did
it but it's not working all they know is
how to reduce the inflammation but
that's a function of some other stuff
well uh that's what happened look at
that one though
a lot of stress it's almost from fish no
fish are stressing me out huh it's more
work it's more work you know that's cool
all right we'll have a conversation I'm
just gonna air it out for a little bit
be fine it's gotten way worse I don't
want to see what my tummy looks like
right now oh yeah you're covered yeah
that's good I was covered at least it's
on your face though thank God it'll get
on your face but not careful it can go
Oh no I got to get it wrong yeah she
goes on my face you won't see me for a
while yeah can't touch the face fine not
the face not the face but I went through
that yeah I remember when you're all
stressed out
Rogan telling me with my shirt off we
were in Vegas I just finished working
out I was in great shape and he goes God
damn he was like that he was like you're
worried I'm worried about you covered
well you should be worried about me but
it never came back
all right let's go on to the next thing
this is so ashy it's gonna it's gonna
get it's so it's clumps of skin so it's
the skin clumps up and produces more
skin cells than you need I guess and
that's what psoriasis is
now the problem with that is that'll
turn the psoriatic arthritis you got to
be careful because you can get arthritis
with that don't take a picture of that
for me so I can send it to my dog well
your dog's not gonna I've been down the
rabbit hole please talk to me your
doctor's not gonna say it your Doc's
going to go like this he's going to go
yep seen it a thousand times yeah go to
that one he's not gonna do anything
if you want to go into heavy drugs you
can I really recommend I strongly
recommend against it I like drugs though
yeah I don't think they're going to work
for that
all right well I've ate so that's cool
enjoy me on the air for the next three
days no it's it's there are certain
things you got to fix about your life
your your stressed about some stuff yeah
I gotta fire more people we're gonna
change to make some changes are they
painful or itchy or no not at all I
don't even know what's happening I don't
even know what's happening I I I I
didn't think it was that bad till I
[__] getting the light yeah and now
anything you eat can I go into hobby
super sensitive about what you eat now
anything you eat you're gonna eat
something like you might have some dairy
or something and all of a sudden it's
gonna boom you think yeah because that's
where your body's at right now
well I don't need Dairy so joke's on you
unless there's pizza around all that
stuff
I'm just sending this to my dog Kanye's
new Australian Broadway okay listen to
the imagination no it's not she smokes a
cigarette bare breasted some base in
tiny bikini and shows off Curves in
newly Unearthed photo so Kanye was
secretly married not too long ago
and the girl is super like super hot she
looks a lot like Kim Kardashian as you
can imagine she is she is just
impossibly hot
damn
I know that'll take your mind off
that'll take your mind off some stuff
that'll take an anti-semitic get you
this
[Laughter]
I'll tell you one God damn one thing we
know she's not Jewish oh man
fine dude it's frustrated God that is
dog stupid and she's brilliant too she's
like a designer for uh I forgot what it
was but yes
my God at his architectural designer at
Yeezy business
um she's well well she built this boat
I don't buy that she does anything but
that but that's all good I don't no she
does that's where they met yeah and
apparently she had to change her hair
color because people were saying she
looks too much like Kim Kardashian I
don't know if that's real or not but
that's her with short hair blonde hair
that body sure her hair I'm a fan
I'm a huge fan I don't care
I don't know where that's they got they
got they got married and celebrated at a
uh an Arby's
but she's smoking hot she is that's
doing weird things in my weiner fellas
get it out of here chin all right God
have you ever heard about this um okay
so this is kind of tricky so there's an
arm Diner yeah someone came in to Rob
I don't know if we can play the video
though so so the video shows a guy
coming in with a mask show Brandon I
want his take on it we won't air it so
this is the guy in the restaurant
because I remember I said if that if I
was around the Asian shooter I'd take
his gun and shoot him so he's got a gun
he's waving around he's stealing from
people this guy needs money because he's
robbing a [__] show I watch this so
this guy right here this Diner yeah he
got him in the back yeah he got him he
murdered him yeah well I get it because
you don't know if the guy's gonna turn
and shoot you I mean you get it [__]
yeah you get it yeah but he's in there
really done he's got to face a grand
jury now it should be 12 nothing no no
because the reason why it's
controversial is because it's back to
him a parano after he shot him he went
back up to the thing yeah but went back
up to the register stand or whatever
handing people back their money and they
came back and shot him in the head again
to make sure he's dead yeah because he
has a gun I mean apparently he was he
was done and he just shot him in the
head again and okay but if he's already
done and he wants to double down on it
and then he never left oh sorry he never
stayed for the police to come he left in
his truck with his partner yeah because
he's a [__] Savage dude you think he
should wait around to give a report well
once guys goddamn hero once we know
exactly what happens it'll make more
sense but if he did it like Sammy the
book ravana right there that looks like
my father the guy is dead already right
he's on the ground dead and then the guy
walks back later and shoots him in the
head and then leaves it's kind of like
what you're doing this for like because
you want to shoot this but it doesn't
matter what maybe he's a sociopath and
he's always wanted to do this I don't
give a [__] if I'm there with my family
my kids this guy does that let me just
look at the guy sitting next to him yeah
and and also the person or the the
people that own the restaurant they're
like calling him a hero they're thankful
that he did hell yeah yeah but I mean I
don't know the details once the
investigation comes out you watched it
you watch the actual video you can see
it is there an actual video yeah but but
also but also for that that piece of
[__] that went in there with a gun
that's the risk you take and where's
this is in Houston so licensing conceal
out there is fine
the big question could he be charged or
was it charged for what being awesome
yeah hey guilty for being awesome yeah
he's pissed he had to kill the guy
because it was yeah he was just a
[__] toy you would be upset but also
if you pretend you have a real gun we
can't assume it's a toy of course not
you're gonna do whatever it is to get
out of there safe and [__] blow his
brains out you're scared You're Heart's
beating yeah dude and I got nothing to
lose I got [__] AIDS you don't think
I'm gonna blow your head off this and
then you're gonna be in Invisalign
you're just following dude I'm slowly
turning to you you're turning into me I
got two more days I know that he's come
off on my birthday oops your birthday's
in two days I never said that let's go
if I rub my skin on yours will you will
use your eyes to come back I'll give you
that for your birthday it's not
contagious oh you think that's okay if I
still go on hot tubs and stuff yep and
put my hands in the fish tank yep won't
make a difference perfect
what else you gotcha give us one more
one more this is great Demar Hamlin
he was at the game on Sunday
but it's cool that he was actually
showed up
I love it this is him
in his own Suites
that was it's his sign
he has a mask on he's covered up we
don't know who this is but it's still a
little delicate in his health it's
likely him
this entire nation wow I love that
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool I
think since I would take it easy on but
they beat the [__] okay I gotta tell you
Cincinnati Niners daddy uh that's
exactly what I think I think they're
going to beat the Chiefs I hope so
my son asked for a Joe Pearl Jersey last
night goddamn right buddy listen guys if
you like football but if you like hockey
I'm in Edmonton
Alberta Edmonton Canada uh the comic
strip February 23rd 24th 25th and I'm in
Nashville Tennessee two three and four
then New York City New York Sony Hall
March 11th that's West Nyack New Jersey
Levity Live March 16 17 18. come get
some oh man you're not here for the
fight campaign March 3rd
I'm not no it's Jon Jones big night oh
[__] that's right doing a big fight man
um back on tour this week I'll bring on
La doing spots next week Friday Saturday
only Springfield Missouri Springfield
Missouri get your tickets now
Naples Florida I'll be doing some
fishing in Naples Naples Florida
February 16th through the 18th one night
only almost sold out Bakersfield
California February 23rd get Joe tickets
step right up get your tickets get
psoriasis uh Springfield I'll see you
next week psoriasis tour next Friday
Saturday February third and fourth
tickets at thickboy.com psoriasis coming
in hot Springfield you got four people
thanks guys we love you